there's a clock on the stove
you're gonna make me be sexist Dan a
woman can't beat me in a sport just stop
it in any sport
any sport
oh okay wait wait let's take Golf out of
this
yes A woman can't beat me in golf for
sure what
a regular person a lot of LPGA Pro
Candace Parker would beat you one on one
Chuck
Hey listen I love working with Candace
he's very talented does a fantastic job
but a woman can't beat me in a sport
dance stop it Dan Charles Candace Parker
is in shape as young
she's good she's a baller well first of
all she's not that young uh but Dad
oh that's awesome
oh that's something you don't see often
a cougar is not in the wild oh man it's
entire August our boss Tara August she's
there giving love is great that's great
goodbye being there in person and I'd
like to see it now so this is Zion
warming up we don't have them it could
be another two three weeks but Chuck you
you had a visceral reaction to this it
looked like me and Shaq had a baby
[Laughter]
quit I gotta get like oh man
you had a baby
over the summer
who's your favorite President chuck oh
Abraham Lincoln okay I'm just yeah I saw
the movie I know you you know why you
know I know I love I love President
Obama but eight link is my new favorite
President why because if it wasn't for
him we'd be calling Ernie boss
yeah
hey this is Charles Barkley I hope
you're enjoying the NBA playoffs on TNT
and I hope you have enjoyed my T-Mobile
phase five list I'm a dumbass
[Applause]
you guys want to see something amazing
yeah because I've seen this thing that's
a big old guitar right there right there
it's a guitar on that's what they is
what they call it so anything that's
bigger you just put a drone on it yeah
it's a Chacarron
oh or I would say women of Rome
doing some unbelievable artwork how
about this yes
with 884
000.
why are you friends
man that's not what I look like little
kids I'm gonna come down there get you
some smoke
stop it man stop it you're going that
little kids tonight come on everybody go
to a commercial break so I can go down
and smack this little kid I don't have a
Runway to go to the right hand side
[Music]
entertainment in Houston I bet you
couldn't do that them big ass women in
San Antonio oh we're not even missing no
you can do nothing
you can't do nothing big old women in
San Antonio
why not you kick one of the big old
women in San Antonio
oh Victoria's Secret down there
before we go uh Tim Kiley our producer
the absolute best in the business so
thanks to TK
and Steve director
what is wrong with you Garrett reifer
the technical director yeah for sure
don't you don't you love this crew
Charles I love the crew but TK and
fiorello ain't on the top of them I'm
being honest right I don't want to be
one of these [ __ ] on television hey
hey hey hey oh I mean jackasses I'm
sorry I apologize
I apologize
these guys should act like they know
everything Ernie I got the first Shaq
that's the first time I've ever cursed
yeah it is it is I apologize Chuck I'll
tell you what I will pay your fine to
the FCC I do I apologize no but the
point I want to make
you know when I heard it right
when did you heard it when I beat Cody
Rhodes up in that wrestling match and he
went me through the table yeah really it
was the table thing wow I thought you
were lifting one of your woman's weaves
[Laughter]
so see when you when you laugh like that
you encourage him and that's not good
well it actually it is good for the show
uh he's just banging and banging and
banging when a guy's banging you
you don't you spin off of him those the
worst Defenders to play against actually
because if you can feel their body uh
come on 18 points for Joker only nugget
in double figures
69-59 Golden State shooting 67. I have a
rough look at a replay then it takes
Charles to get in a pair of skinny jeans
it was wrong too well first of all Jamal
you're a cashier so shut the hell up
nothing wrong with me
he might be a cashier a dude can't be a
cashier
you can't go home and tell your kids Hey
Dad how was everything and catch a
cashier today
come on man dude can't be a cashier I
can't tell people your daddy
it's an analogy it's a metaphor you take
your kid my dad's a policeman my dad's a
firefighter my dance alone what's your
dad do he'll cashier in public
when he saw the best talking to Joshua
oh stop man no stop hey here's here's a
question yeah
the reason I'm hot is your breath
uh like a it's like a furnace coming on
my damn neck over here
[Music]
[Music]
Sunday night at 10 34 Chuck for uh for
viewership oh oh this was a big night
tonight we got Texas is a big state
Utah's not that big we got all of Texas
we got Amarillo Austin Seguin El Paso
Seguin Dallas Dallas
oh and we weighed them twice please
do that
oh
God woke up twice already Victor welcome
to my world this is what you do Chuck
we've got him twice
Ernie yeah that uh hyper hyper thing
Kenny gave me one yes the vibrator yeah
no I didn't give you a vibrator yes you
did I gave you a hyper vote Yes you did
I give you a vibrations
[Laughter]
that's the most ridiculous one over
there that's still living that what you
would say has no chance of happening
um two two black guys beat the black guy
up and have him
the Clippers well the Clippers will not
make the playoffs let me explain maybe I
didn't do a good job
the pressure was on
it feels yeah
Boss Of God fat boy let me explain what
I meant screwed up alone thank you very
much for what they sent me two boxes of
underwear so what are you gonna do with
it I'm gonna give them to a homeless
shelter well I hope well there's no
almost it has four X's
homeless shelter
boy let me tell you something Kenny uh
the fruit alone that was very nice thank
you and let me just tell you something
in the back I was giving them out a few
of the guys got them they got some
smaller sizes but I'ma just say this
about some of the women who work here oh
they're a little overconfident they can
fit in the big draws oh man you're going
there some of y'all need to check y'all
Pride at the door come on y'all
defending them things are those